we've been graphing in the complex plane
recently and this is one of the
equations
that we encountered and i walked you
through in class
how we could go about working out the
subset of the complex plane the the set
of points that would satisfy this
equation and we did it in a very visual
and intuitive way
but i know that is quite frustrating to
some people because it can sometimes
feel as though
if you hadn't been shown the kind of the
trick or the insight that would help you
understand
where the points were on the complex
plane that would satisfy this equation
you just won't
know where to begin and that's one of
the key strengths
of taking an algebraic approach to
things you don't necessarily need to
know
in advance what kind of a shape you're
going to end up with you just kind of
start to simplify things
and then the algebra takes care of the
rest now there are huge problems with
that approach
usually it is very long and drawn out
and as a consequence
it can also be very error prone because
the more steps there are the more places
there are for mistakes to creep in
however
it's really important that you do get a
handle on how to do these kinds of
things
um so that if you do encounter an
equation you're like i don't even know
where to begin this doesn't look like
the kind of shape it's not a circle or
parabola or hyperbola that i've you know
encountered before just with different
numbers
i might need to know how to work out the
shape of something
from scratch so that's what i'm going to
show you how to do with this particular
equation
i hope that part of what i'm going to do
is convince you why the algebraic
approach
is not ideal and it has significant
problems with it but
if you ever want to lean on it i'll show
you kind of the skeleton of how i go
about it
now just in case you haven't seen the
you know the previous lesson on which
this one is kind of following on from
let's review right we encountered this
equation and then to think about it
in visual terms what i did was i
added r g of z minus 3 to both sides
which then presented me with
this argument being equal to this
argument i replaced it
slightly on this line just to show uh
more specifically what the reference
point um
in this case is negative i in this case
it's three what the two reference points
were
for this particular subset of the
complex plane and then what we did was
we
explored visually we use some software
to
think about if i move z to different
places where could it be
that i would find the argument to that
particular complex
point that i selected where would the
argument be the same from
minus i and also from three now where we
ended up with our conclusion
was that this was the subset of the
complex plane that satisfied
all of those if you just have a think
for example about let's let's pick a
point over here
i'm saying that that could be a
potential value for z
and when you think about the angle
measured to that point from say 3
it's going to be this angle here from
the positive real axis
upwards it'll be this little angle here
and if you have think about
the argument from i don't know why that
says i that should be negative i
let's fix that shall we there we go if
we again have a look at the argument
from that
point as you're headed up if you aimed
properly that would help
i'm on the same line and you measure
from the same positive real direction
you can see this is literally just
corresponding angles
on parallel lines so that's why the
angles are the same
the arguments are the same and you could
make the same argument
you could make the the same point if you
were on the other side use the same
logic right all of these points on these
two
black lines are right however we did
notice that in the middle here
if we picked a spot like this the
argument from minus i would be different
to the argument from
three and so we excluded that little
interval in the center so
this was our conclusion right when you
have something presented to you
in this form the two points here
negative i
and three in this case are joined by an
interval
and to get the set of points or the
locus that is relevant to this
you extend that interval out so you end
up getting these two rays here's
one ray heading off to infinity in that
direction
and then here's the other ray heading in
the opposite direction you extend the
interval out and then
the interval itself gets excluded it's
not part of the set of points that
you're after
so this is what we ended up with but how
would we go about this without just sort
of
appealing to that hand waviness or the
fact that you already know
what this shape should be how can we use
algebra to help us
what we need to do is a couple of things
number one we will be doing a lot of
algebra
but number two we actually need to take
a step back and reestablish or review
some foundational knowledge that we'll
need to use in the course of our
algebraic
proof and we're going to do something
which we're very fond of doing
in mathematics and particularly in this
topic we're going to look at
complex numbers from two different
perspectives that will give us insights
that help us with this question so let's
have a go at doing this
from scratch and if you're following
along with notes
let's call this the algebraic technique
all right now what is this foundational
piece of knowledge that
i was alluding to the foundational piece
of knowledge is that we have to deal
with
this cartesian equation x's and y's and
all that kind of thing
but we have to get there via
understanding the arguments i mean this
equation that was presented to us here
it's all about arguments there's no
modulus or anything else uh
inside no conjugates or other things
like that where the algebra is
relatively simple
so i i need to work out what algebraic
tools can help me to deal with the
arguments in this question
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
say let's remember
if we take a complex number and if the
complex number is say for example
a plus ib if i have it in rectangular or
cartesian form
i can relate that to its um its argument
by stating the same complex number
in in a different form right i could say
in polar form or in exponential form i'm
going to use polar form here just
because
i think it will tease out the
relationships a little more obviously
so a an arbitrary complex number stated
in polar form
would be r cos theta plus i sine theta
so instead of a horizontal and a
vertical component like you have in
cartesian form
we've got our modulus here and we've got
our argument in
here and as long as you know what
direction you're facing it and how far
you should go in that direction
that uniquely defines a complex number
on the complex plane
so this is a foundational how do i get
this to help me well
i'm going to make this comparison
between the left and the right hand side
by doing a bit of an expansion here so
if i just
expand these brackets i get this
and what you can see is i can take the
real terms
on the left and the real terms on the
right and i can say well these must be
equal
right the real parts on the left and
right and then the imaginary parts on
the left and right which are
respectively here
there's the real parts and then here
there is the imaginary parts i can make
the comparison between them
and say well that these two must be
equal because there's no other part in
the equation for the imaginary
components to come from
and uh same with these part these must
be equal okay
now uh rather than go and just say you
know
a equals this b equals this i'm going to
go one step further and you'll see why
in a second i'm actually going to do a
bit of a division here right so i'm
going to say
we'll use these colors here right b
over a this is the uh imaginary part
divided by
the real parts in fact i should say that
i'm comparing
the real and imaginary
part if i do a division
of the imaginary component by the real
component on the left hand side
that is equivalent to doing a division
of the imaginary
component divided by the real component
on the
right hand side so i'm going to get r
sine theta
on the numerator and then i'm going to
get r
cos theta on the denominator so at this
point
i can simplify this out because i'm
getting r's that cancel
1 2 and then sine theta over cos theta
of course i can just write this as
tan theta okay now how is this useful to
me
well remember theta in this case is the
argument that's relevant
to this particular complex number so i
can start to get things in terms of
you know what my original question looks
like you can see this is written in the
form of
argument of a number in rectangular form
so i'm going to take that and i'm going
to write it here
sort of instead of writing theta even
the theta is a much more succinct way of
saying it
i'm going to write it on the left hand
side so i'm going to say
tan instead of writing theta
it's the argument of the complex number
that i started with which i can either
say as
r cos theta plus i sine theta can i put
it in polar form
or i can write a rectangular form the
same number after all right
so i'm going to write it as a plus i b
tan of that argument equals b on
a at this point i want to remind you
that we
strenuously cautioned you in using um
you know tan
inverse to find out what the argument
was because if
for example you had some complex number
and b over a was equal to 1 over
2. if you did tan inverse of that you
would get an
angle out you would get an argument and
it would be in the first quadrant
but if you had a different complex
number and it was
negative one over negative two if that
was the imaginary and the real
components
on the numerator and the denominator if
you put this into tan inverse you get
exactly the same
result you'll get a first quadrant angle
even though if your imaginary component
is negative one and your real component
is negative two
you're not in the first quadrant you are
in the third
quadrant when both are negative so we
said don't use this to actually find the
argument unless you know you're in a
real hurry or you have no choice
however what i've got here is is always
true i've not introduced any inverse
trig functions
it's just regular old tan of an angle
equals this ratio